Ever thought about how insane submarines are? No?
Well, I do. I think about this all the time. I'm
not talking about these cute little science
explorers. I'm talking about these massive
military nuclear attack submarines, these
windowless spaceships of the ocean strapped
with ballistic missiles that have nuclear warheads
on them. These things travel underwater in stealth
mode through complete darkness for months at a
time. They move slowly to avoid making noise so
they won't be detected by enemies. They're
even coated with rubbery tile that absorbs
sound so that sonar can’t bounce up against
them. So the question I always have is like,
don't they run into things like whales or
something? It turns out they don't. I mean,
most of the time they don't. They put out
sound into the ocean and whatever it bounces
off gives them a map of what is ahead of them.
But also, maps! Look at these beautiful maps
of the ocean floor. But sometimes they're
wrong. In 2005, this submarine ran into an
underground mountain because of an error
in one of their maps. Well, regardless,
I would rather take my chance out there on the
ocean. Submarines are really freakin’ cool.